[Music]  Quentin Tarantino the director of the  controversial movie Django Unchained  recently had a contentious interview  with Britain's channel 4 about the link  between movie violence and real violence  Quentin believes there is no connection  but I think he could have found a more  effective way to make his argument check  out the interview but why are you so  sure that there's no link between  enjoying movie violence and enjoying  real violence it's none of your damn  business what I think about that well  it's my job to ask you boys and I am  shutting your butt down I'm gonna  violence so do not ask me a question  like that I'm not gonna I'm not biting I  refuse your question I enjoy your movies  thank you very much  [Applause]  way to go